ici les cuisiniers préparent leurs
ustensiles comme cupidon prépare ses
flèches tous les ans ce restaurant de
mort pas célèbre la fête des amoureux
autour d'un repas spécial cette année
sera un duo terre et mer on a voulu
d'abord principalement rester dans le
thème rouge de la saint valentin
donc nous sommes partis se rend en
entrée une déclinaison de mollo de
betteraves et son carpaccio de thon
mariné à la sauce ponzu et pour le plat
ça nous a permis on a fait un diot
ardent de terremer donc pour plaire à
l'homme et pour plaire aussi à la femme
avec le poisson est pour l'homme le
magret de canard la soirée saint
valentin ce serait agréable c'est une
soirée le couple principalement avec une
ambiance on va dire peut-être un peu
plus romantiques crois que c'est pour
tout le monde aussi bien jeunes moins
jeunes que plus anciens on va dire il ya
vraiment pas d'âge pour la saint
valentin pour terminer le repas un
élixir du désir composé de gingembre
cannelle et safran mariner dans un vieux
rhum comptait 58 euros le menu par
personne
la soirée peut se poursuivre dans un
lieu atypique les yourtes de l'île de
loisirs offre un cadre intime et des
paysans des yourtes y en a cinq
il ya une yourte qui fait 66 m² qui est
consacré un espace cuisine donc
complètement équipée et 4 soup qui
servent de couchage donc de yourtes de 8
et de yourtes de deux s'échauffer c'est
tranquille ça permet je pense de passer
un petit séjour romantique agréable et
originale pour passer la nuit à la
manière mongol prévoyez 60 euros la
saint valentin une tradition toujours
qualifié de romantique par 69% des
français selon un sondage au doxa
l'occasion de raviver la flamme de
l'amour